whatever your goal demands your goal
ultimately will be translated into math
so it is very simple what do you need to
do on this day to achieve your goal do
you do it or not it really is that cut
and dry and if you're looking over your
shoulder for somebody to save you I can
tell you right now they are not coming
no one is coming to help you this is
something that you have to do for
yourself and I hope in hearing all of
this you realize why 92% of people fall
into the category of I gave up I quit I
knew what my goal was or I didn't have
enough Clarity but I didn't do the
things that I needed to do in order to
cross the finish line it really is that
simple